that most is a little strong you know I
make them mostly champagne hey guys I'm
Bryce sander this is housewives happy
hour and Phaedra Parks is back oh it's
so good to see how are you I'm wonderful
cheers to you here's the happy season at
9:00 ready hit it chef let's talk you
your life mm-hmm
still pursuing a divorce oh well I'm
actually divorced divorced completely
done yes I am done
was that a sense of relief well you know
motion well it's it was very
anti-climatic shall I say it's
bittersweet I mean it's been a very long
hectic process but at the end of the day
you know I'm excited to start a new
chapter in my life we were a family and
so this is pretty much the death of that
family unit so it was it's sad because
you know it is what it is but now
looking forward you send another mm-hmm
what does this new chapter look like for
you I don't know the divorce is very new
and I'm just taking my time I'm anxious
for nothing and so you know my first
party is always you know being a great
mother and so I've got two great boys
and we're finally really getting
adjusted and in the swing of things I
will probably date at some point but
right now you know I'm just letting it
all soak in the newness of it and you
know if you date me you date the boys we
come as a big threesome when that moment
does go home what kind of man are you
looking for the perfect guy would be a
god-fearing guy guy who loves children
who loves my sons as much as I do
someone who's generous smart witty me
with a penis would you want to get
married again oh I'll definitely get
married again yeah I mean I haven't
given up on love I mean to know love is
better to not know
I'm excited to see this new chapter for
you and yeah I'm excited too it's gonna
be great cheers to you cheers as he's a
nine oh and thank you for stopping by
thank you for having me
you